five four
three
two
okay folks episode number 140 with the
one and only king of cards ken golden
from golden auctions ken how you doing
i'm doing great patrick we hear you
typing uh tyler
i like you typing fast we can turn that
off for some of you guys that don't know
who ken goldin is here's what i will
tell you if you've been following uh
bitcoin nft stocks real estate whatever
you're following and you're not looking
at the collectible market
you're going to want to stick around
today for a couple different reasons ken
i think in 2012
golden auctions did 800 000
i want to say in 2020 or 2021 give or
take you did 100 million dollars 2020.
2020 did 100 million dollars and last
month alone you did a little over 40
million dollars correct which is
insanity this isn't cards we're talking
about right
collectible cards and comics and some of
the other stuff but we'll get into that
folks stick around meanwhile before we
get into everything i want to make an
announcement to you
we just got word this morning it's all
over the place if you want to put it up
tyler so we can just get right into it
we'll comment into this before we get
into uh ken golden and others and i
think matt is on his way but his
flight's been delayed four or five times
he's going to join us right in the
middle of it
so breaking news twitter shares soars
more than 20 after elon musk takes nine
percent stake in social media company so
let me get this straight so he's been
teasing that he's going to buy
or if he should start a company we
talked about this whether he should team
up with broken or not and peter thiel he
buys
73.486 million shares which is 9.2
percent bought it for 2.89 billion
within the first few hours i think the
stock went up 25
now is 20 which means on his 3 billion
he's already made 600 million dollars
himself and here's a kicker some people
are like well i got a text right now
from a ceo of a major social media
company he says
why is he saying passive which is a
great question he's asking me why is he
saying passive because i'm just a
passive investor i'm just a passive
investor in twitter right elon musk is
saying to a passive investor
if you can look at who the biggest
shareholders or twitter are look at this
here why it's so interesting zoom in a
little bit
morgan stanley dean witter owns how much
9.2 percent what did elon musk buy nine
point two percent nine point two now why
didn't he buy nine percent why not nine
point one why eight point eight who buys
nine point two percent of shares you
only buy nine point two percent of
shares to say i'm the largest
shareholder tying morgan stanley ahead
of vanguard group who's third by the way
if you can go a little lower black
rockers third state street corp is
fourth
lone pine capital is fifth now he's the
same as morgan stanley dean witter so
if you're listening to this i kind of
want to see your commentary below what
you think his motives are i'm going to
give you mine but ken what are your
thoughts about this announcement here
i mean obviously he's had some
issues with uh twitter and um when you
have that type of money you can wield
your influence and i'm he's saying
passive because basically he's saying
he's not going to be
an activist investor you know not going
to demand a change
but i think he's probably doing it and
say okay guys um
try and delete me try and ban me try and
uh take me down now
and um you know realistically when you
have that type of money you
may want to live your life quietly and
peacefully or you may want to let people
know that there is a uh gorilla in the
room and
you're going to impose um your will
yeah i like i like hearing that can can
you check your phone is your phone
verizon or a tnt it's a verizon okay can
you turn it off because i don't know if
you need to or not okay if you can turn
off the airplane the airplane mode would
be great sometimes it picks it up and if
you need to turn it on afterwards you
can sure so
is this uh because this is breaking news
we're all just finding this out this
morning is this an economic play is this
some sort of political play you know is
this a social media play we're talking
about
you know try to cancel rogan see what
happens if you try to cancel rogan and
pull him off with spotify who's the
first call that he makes you you did a
clip where he's the first call he makes
is elon musk and you bring in peter
thiel and who knows what they can create
so it's kind of like he's stepping in
here to say all right
i've heard the rumors out there of what
i should be doing or i should not be
doing so where do you think his mindset
is doing this on a random monday morning
on is this in april fools we're april
4th first of all ken knows this when
you're an operator building equity you
don't see anything helping increase your
net worth or value than building up a
company right i mean you just look at
that you're like
what do i care about buying twitter do i
need my three billion dollars to triple
no do i need my three to become 12
billion i promise you that's the last
thing he's thinking this is not an
economic plan
if he wants to do that he'll just put
three billion dollars and start another
company instead of calling it boring
he'll call it lame you know
just go build that into a multi-billion
dollar company make his money back no
there is a motive behind this you better
believe it uh this reminds me of the the
the scene from bugs you ever seen the
movie bugsy yes with ben siegel you've
seen the movie you know that one scene
when he's driving in beverly hills and
it's nice cadillac i don't know what car
it was and he pulls up to this house and
he's like i like this house he gets out
of the car goes knocks on the door he
says yes what can i help you with i'm
buying your house
it's not for sale yeah i know but i'm
buying your house you need to move up no
no you don't understand we're not
selling this house yes you are what's
the value i'll pay you 50 more than
sport you need to move out he buys the
house right
elon has the kind of money to just go in
and say hey guys you need to move out
this is my little thing here get out i'm
buying this now here's the thing so
there is no
he's not making a move just because he's
just making a move just to make a move
guys like him don't do things like that
that sounds like that's an active
investor if you if you're asking me yeah
does it sound too impressive but he
broke it down which is very important
you know he doesn't want the
responsibilities
of an active investor but what would be
crazy is the following okay there's only
one guy crazier that many people on you
know mainstream media may not want to
buy twitter and that guy's a different
guy this is the one guy nobody wants
buying twitter because now if he takes
control and people were bashing jack
dorsey a lot
when he resigned and they're like well
so glad he's gone and all this other
stuff now a lot of people are starting
to realize maybe jack didn't have as
much power as he once did with the
voting rights so imagine if elon calls
jack then there's a comeback like uh you
know brady coming back or a michael
coming back or ma you know great analogy
right there for our card game and then
all of a sudden you know jack dorsey
teams up with his paypal mafio buddy
elon musk to take you know twitter to
the next level what percentage do you
think dorsey still owns i don't know
what it is i don't know if it's a big
number you think that's less than nine
there's no question there's no question
no
there's no question i may be wrong there
may be a twelve percent number but uh
thirteen percent number is what it is
two percent two percent there you go
okay two percent but
yeah two percent so
elon musk is now sitting there so who
knows what's gonna happen now there's a
few other things i mean if he's really
wanted to fulfill his move
if elon really wants to fulfill his move
he needs to buy a wapo and he needs to
buy a cnn
meaning not wapo because wapo's owned by
bezos there's no way he's no way yeah
exactly but he needs to buy a guapo like
mark benihoff bought time magazine bezos
bought you know wapo peter bought la
times or like 551 or some number like
that he needs to buy something like that
and then he needs to buy a media company
a cnn he can afford to buy if he made a
move to buy cnn
people would lose their minds if this
guy made some of those man let me ask
you because up until now correct me if
i'm wrong he doesn't own anything in the
media or social media space does he i
don't know if he does or not okay so
obviously tesla obviously spacex the
boring company the neurolink it's up
until this point it's all been
you know electric or moon or space or
something next level
go to his deepest darkest desires that
nobody even thinks about what is elon
doing with this if this is his first
foray into media or social media or as
you call uh virtual governments
go there where do you think he's
thinking i don't know i think elon musk
is about freedom of voice and expression
and he just wants to give that back to
himself and others and he's probably
worried that he's pushing the envelope
too much that he may be the next guy to
be silent so why not buy an insurance
policy like you and i buy life insurance
policy i'm sure you want a key man
insurance policy this is his way of
buying his own key management try to
cancel me i think it's a brilliant
brilliant move hats off to this guy uh
but uh yeah very very good movie so it's
a defensive move if anything at the very
least you're saying yeah i mean when you
see
buffett buys silver what are you doing
buying silver
you know what are you doing buying
certain things that you buy it's purely
defensive you do it in collectible
industry as well but you were going to
say something go ahead i was going to
say something about elon is
the guy can wake up on the side of the
bed and decide i'm going to do that
today i mean i'm wondering who he told
before he was doing this did he clear it
with his general counsel did he talk to
financial advisors did just one day go
out and tell somebody by nine point two
percent twitter because i mean he's
crazy it is elon musk i mean he is
capable of spending
five billion dollars whatever he did do
if you have to put your like 50 50 80 20
do you think he did or you think he just
made a move
um
i would think it's 50 50. okay so wow so
are you saying you think he called
anybody do you think he called to want
to talk to him he didn't call his uh
baby mama ex-girlfriend
what's her face my uh
grimes
if there's anyone that strikes me as as
someone who's like what do you think
guys here's what i'm thinking i think
elon would would seek some counsel he
seems very reasonable
and even if someone said don't do it i
think he's uh at the ken's point of view
you're more 70 30 yeah
what about you pat
he made me think about i wasn't even
thinking about that until ken said that
i don't know to be honest with you
because
i would i would say
he asked because he's got the next three
four five moves in place i'm probably 70
30. how long do you think he's been
thinking about this oh few months ever
since spotify tried to take broken down
ever since a bunch of people have been
silenced on twitter ever since jack
dorsey resigned i think this has been on
his mind for a couple years now you're
not shocked that this is his first
play into media meaning it's not
facebook it's not google it's not
youtube it's specifically twitter
i'm not at all and i don't think it's
going to be the last one but what is
what is kind of shocking is that it's
elon musk that elon musk is becoming
this bastion of freedom and free speech
i mean it's not like he's a conservative
dude right he's supposedly red pill but
he left remember when he left the trump
administration because all the backlash
he was getting very early in 2016 yeah
he was counseling the administration and
he left you know this is one of the big
knocks of the people on the right is
that they
they're people with tons of money on the
right but they throw it all at these uh
think tanks that can't do anything that
don't do anything they just waste it but
you know peter thiel just just left
facebook he was on the board of facebook
for what 15 years he just left and now
elon musk is the guy that's stepping up
i mean i think
i think he's going to cause a wave of
people to step up behind it and say
listen we have to put our foot down and
get on these boards spend our money the
right way do it correctly and put up a
fight because
the fact that they can silence i mean
twitter and facebook have more power
than most government organizations
around the world right they can
literally silence anybody they choose
it's about time that people like elon
musk and peter thiel and all those step
up and why does you know what i'm
looking forward to seeing here's what
i'm looking forward to seeing
i can't wait to hear the commentary of
people who hate the elon musk i can't
wait to hear elizabeth warren's thoughts
on this i can't wait to hear what
they're going to say
about a capitalist that's creating jobs
making the economy a better place
they're talking about ev let's make it
greener whatever ain't nobody's been
trying to do that more than this guy he
started the revolution he started the
game he gets the least amount of credit
for it so anyways we'll see what's going
to happen and just wait until the
government goes after it man i would not
be surprised at all if the sec tried to
go after why are you putting that in
their ears right
to
if
scc
turn tyler down a little bit a little
loud right now in general and now he's
getting a little massive how many shots
of tequila did you have to be honest did
you start with your regular two or i
only had the three
but seriously let's turn tyler down
georgie you were able how do i turn my
headset down can we get exactly it's a
little loud get ken down ten percent get
ken down ten percent ken on behalf of
valuetainment and pb i'm sorry for tyler
that was aggressive okay so so that was
a mickey mantle that was the day
was a little bit more than 10 george if
you can bring it back up slightly okay
so uh uh today you have a surprise for
us you said you brought a box do you
want to show them what you brought i
don't know if you have it with you
outside it's in the green room is it the
green room can i have one the guys grab
it and bring it so we can maybe uh break
it but they just bring the whole bag
because i've got supplies in there too
bring them back baby can you uh whoever
is in there send somebody to go to the
green room he's got a box
to open up but while they're doing that
tell us what you just did with some
famous guys some people may know last
week on the day that wils made that
whole story tell us what just happened
so i flew to uh flute to toronto okay
with a box of 1986 fleer basketball
cards can you put that up there so
people can't see where it originally
came out
at probably 25 50 cents a pack
went down in 88 to like 4.99 on closeout
and now is about a 300 000 box of cards
so we opened up that box and then we
opened up ten cases thank you ten cases
of a product called uh 2020 panini
flawless basketball
which is a obviously a modern product
but people are looking for
this very special lebron james card that
has the logo off his jersey from all
three teams he played for cleveland
miami and uh the lakers
so we were there i was up in toronto at
a you know private gathering and um
spent about six hours with uh
with drake uh about four of it opening
up cards and uh two hours of it watching
the oscars and eating so so so this
whole thing with oscars is going on
you're watching it live while you guys
are opening up cards what happened there
when he's uh you know so we met so we um
we
you know took did a promo shot yeah
showed what we're gonna do you and drake
yourself yeah yeah drake and i draco
let's just let's not gloss over the fact
that you're spending six hours of drake
opening up cards
by the way can you just show that real
quick can uh you give us permission to
show that or no sure yeah absolutely if
you want to show clipping out of that
you can go uh go on you can go on atken
golden it's probably all the best videos
yeah go to atkin golden
uh is that at ken golden or who is that
gold yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah right there okay so which one you
want to show so show the um show the one
with me holding uh six uh six cards
right there okay go to the left oh that
one right there put the audio
so there's canon drizzy oh here we go so
right off the bat you can see
that is a uh on the back of the card's a
sticker yeah
so we've got a kareem sticker on the
back
let's see
drake
now is drake a collector or no uh drake
uh actually in about a minute opens up
his first ever pack of cards ever in his
life ever he said ever in his life
and how did you guys get hooked up
uh what happened was he was and i'll
tell you when to click it back live as
soon as you see him go to do it and you
know he's got some of his friends there
we're drinking he actually said you know
the first thing he goes okay we're gonna
do whoever gets the better packs you
know the next guy has to take a shot and
i'm like
i will not be here if i take 20 shots i
don't know i don't know what you're like
but uh that's not gonna be uh that's not
gonna be me great game he just starts
but
drake was looking for this card and he
was doing it by using breakers and
breakers are people who actually open
boxes of cards for you so they do it on
youtube they do it on instagram live
they do it on the other social media
apps and you buy into a break and
they'll open the cards and hope you pull
a big card so drake was doing that with
um with a breaker and then hopped on to
my instagram live about two weeks ago
and you know
i went in with somebody and we had a
bunch of cases and we started opening up
cases and what i did was i did what's
called a case war with drake where we
each opened up a box and whoever got the
better cards out of the box
got the other person's box and these are
20 000 boxes two three four five six at
a time so um you know it got a lot of
publicity a lot of attention nice you
know and but i i felt that
you know
you can't it doesn't give the same
effect as if you're there with him
because all you see is champagne popping
and people can be pessimists and they
can say i bet that's a social media guy
typing in i bet it's not really drake
because you know he wasn't showing his
face so
we uh arranged for uh
cases to be brought to him in toronto
and you know i didn't tell anybody
because it's drake i mean you can say no
at the last minute and um you know he'd
originally contacted um a gentleman who
runs a publicity site for trading card
card uh called card porn and he looped
me in and uh we put it together and we
flew up there and um
made it happen and instead of just the
flawless i also
during my live i
behind my shelf i have this box of 86
flair and i held it and drake said oh
wow 86 flier michael jordan rookie
that's really cool so i surprised him
and i brought that box with me
to uh to toronto so i said before we do
the flawless we're going to open up this
flare box and that's really
where all of the
excitement happened and i believe
he is about in a moment to open up his
um
his first pack of cards if we want to go
back um we'll check it out in a second
so he's looking and he didn't want to
touch the cards he you know they're
fragile you know these packs as an
individual pack can sell for 7 500 to 10
000 per pack one pack and there's 10 uh
36 packs
in every box so i said no i'm not going
to come out here and you know and have
you not do it people want to people want
to see you open the cards you know let's
let's open the cards so um let's uh
let's see what okay oh we missed it okay
um
here we go
let's take a peek
is this the one he's oh this is the
first time is this the um this is my
pack let's see what he does
oh that's here we go world be free
we'll be free
almost as good as men of world peace no
that's world be free is very way better
jerry sitching
eric
short this i think is his fourth pack
because uh
vern fleming and a magic johnson
did you ever open up cards did you ever
open up when i was a kid yeah i loved it
when i was 10 12 years old basically so
he pulled the first pack he opened um
he pulled a um
michael jordan rookie first the first
yeah so i mean i don't know you want to
go um
you know it's got to be up there
somewhere but um basically so yeah so he
like he was hooked and uh
people like a lot of nba players were
joining in uh logan paul uh joined in um
you know other rappers were joining them
people were just going crazy every
everybody uh everybody loved it but
before we broke
um and there's there's a picture of the
jordan uh one of the jordan rookies
that jordan right there is how much if
you can a psa 10 of that goes for what a
psa 10 goes for about the facility of
275 000 to 325 000 per card we pulled
three of that exact card and we pulled
three of the jordan rookie stickers but
also in there you know the reason it's
so iconic is it was the first major
basketball product um in years
so it had the rookie cards of patrick
ewing charles barkley akimolajon clyde
drexler chris mullen isaiah thomas so
many others
so there are so many cards in there that
if they grade properly could be five
thousand to fifteen thousand dollars a
card there's one oddity a a no-name
player named johnny moore but his card
is scarce in a ten
one of them graded a 10 recently sold
for 90 000
i mean he's like a common otherwise but
if you can get the card in the 10
because there's only about 60 of them
and everybody wants to get a complete
set with all the cards in a 10 it's very
valuable wow it's kind of crazy it's a
common
but there's only 60 of them to have a
complete set of psa tens
you need this guy to get a 10 and it's a
90k yes nobody could even tell you who
johnny moore is no absolutely not you
just made him famous yes again it's been
since 84 last time let me ask you we've
all sort we have all sorts of guests on
we just had jank wieger on the other day
we've got a you know a laundry list of
amazing names that are coming on this
week
what is it about ken and what is it
about cards that appeals to you that
you're like we gotta have talk to ken
because you've been you know quite
on a unabashedly unashamedly been a card
collector for years so what's your story
with all of you
for me look he started i think you
started collecting cards and 78 is the
story i read i was born in 78 but the
first time i got a card was an 89 in
germany when germany was in the world
cup i went to a local liquor store and
they were selling these packs for like
nothing
50 fennec or you know when i and i
bought a pack i opened i'm like oh my
gosh a good disguise and then i was
addicted i was hooked oh yeah and then i
came to la the first time i got a big
card
was uh you remember the one where you
would pull up the upper deck card of
shaq and you have to mail it in and they
would mail them which card was yeah so
it was 1992. yeah and then here's the
here's the story the reason that you had
to mail it in was because in 1992 i ran
a company and i owned a company called
uh classic and i signed shaq exclusively
to a contract and i'll tell the story um
and what happened was i met shaquille
o'neal signed him to a contract and i
put in his contract that he is not
allowed to appear on anybody else's
trading cards until january 1st 1993 i
knew the significance of what doing that
meant because i knew that the mba has
licensees i was not one of them i knew
they had licensees that start putting
out cards in september prior to the
season good move um so when
you know i sent a letter a legal letter
to the mba
tops upper deck and flir after i signed
them saying we have this contract you
better not violate it i was summoned by
david stern to the mba office and shook
my hand met me and then put me in a room
with at the time the deputy commissioner
of the nba a gentleman by the name of
gary bettman who um of course for many
people know him now for many years as
commissioner of the national hockey
league
and he
went on a profanity-laced
tirade to shaquille o'neal's agent and
then basically said
to me
um you know i should hold shaq out from
appearing in any game until he's allowed
to appear on our licensees cards
and this is um october no no
reading you or stern batman oh batman
batman stern stern was very nice stan
said hi nice to meet you blah blah blah
let's you know hope you guys can work
this out um but batman was
berating shaq's lawyers um and like
trying to get me upset and i was i was a
young kid in my 20s i wasn't going to be
i just wasn't going to be phased by any
of this stuff so finally he said we can
you know we can hold shaq out
from playing in the nba until he's
allowed to appear on a card and my
response was that's fine for me because
i'll already be sold out of my trading
card product but i don't think the
orlando magic who just selected him
number one and signed him to that big
contract would appreciate that and then
his face turned red and we ended up
working out a deal and the deal was that
i said hey i'm a publicly owned company
we issued a press release that said no
other card company can do this we are
not going to let any other card company
do it however
they can put in a coupon and if somebody
pulls that coupon out of a pack on
january 1st they can be sent a card of
shaquille o'neal and that invented the
redemption card that was the very first
redemption card in history and that they
had what upper deck did was they put a
silhouette of shacks uh in black and
white and it was called a trade trade-in
for shaq and what's funny is
if you did not send in that redemption
card it's worth more than the actual
card you redeemed for because everybody
of course sent it in and so few of them
exist uh not redeemed right yeah that
would have been 1992-93
upper deck series one basketball so i
got that card and i got a uh another
stadium club uh you know the stadium
club he's rebounding it coming down with
it beam team yeah and then uh uh during
that time upper deck had a uh 91 or 92
sergey fedorov and yarmouyaga rookie car
that was coming out during that era so i
would go to albertson's no joke my mom
would go to sleep at 11 out of shopping
cart in the back of the apartment in
glendale off of uh broadway and
broadway in verdugo right by the post
office i'd go leave the house get on the
shopping cart go to all the trash cans
locally collect two liter bottles and
cans go to albertsons by two o'clock i
would recycle this with my friend adrian
then we would come back just to be able
to buy a box of upper deck to get a
sergey fed off in yarmouth that's how
much i loved cars this was your thing oh
man this was like i'd go to all the
shows the eagle rock show
any of the shows that were local i'd go
to it so and did did it ever stop
meaning like you did this as a teenager
then when you're in my 20s you're
focusing on business took a break from
you know military probably 97 to 04 i
took a break and then i got back into it
and then i deployed a few million in the
last few years but that's that's a
that's a whole different story so so
coming back to you today some some of
the guys that are looking at cards and
by the way if you want to put that box
out so we can see what box you have i'm
curious to know what you brought with
you ken's brought a box it's a surprise
i didn't know about this box okay so
this is what can you tell us what's
special about this box it is 2003 tops
chrome nba basketball and the key with
it is you've got the rookie class that
features lebron james as the number one
draft pick
the what they call the bass card of
lebron and i'll just go over psa 10
values because it's easy that's like a
top grade uh the base card of lebron is
probably in the 8 000 range but they
have a card
that is called refractor which is
randomly inserted of lebron
that's about a hundred thousand dollars
a card and then if you're really lucky
um they have an x factor and a gold
refractor the gold refractor in a psa 10
is about a 1.5 million dollar card
that's that's so and
and and not the key is not they're all
numbered those are numbered to 50 not
all of them have been pulled which means
somewhere out there in some of these
unopened boxes exists this potential
million dollar plus trading card so for
somebody that doesn't know a box like
this goes for what 20 bucks 40 bucks 80
bucks uh that box is in the vicinity of
twenty five thousand dollars a box this
is a twenty five thousand dollar box
here today so should we open this box or
no on live yeah yeah yeah i think we
should
split the profits and i'll just go live
our best live
we'll put that over here by the way if
you if you want to see us open this box
let us know through super chat we'll pay
attention to it i mean obviously we're
not going to raise 25k but if you want
us to open that up let us know we may do
it on this part what i what i do want to
do before i go to use the follow up okay
ken
for some people that are like come on
man baseball cards i mean why the hell
would a trading card
sell for as much as it does an article
came out
uh recently talking about the top 10
most expensive cards ever sold now
you're going gonna correct this article
i'm certain of it it's on page three
it says uh number ten is honest wagner
t206 206 psa five
sold for 3.1 million a psa 300 wagner
sold for 3.7 million
a uh wayne gretzky 79 opt the one i sold
for 2.1 million sold for 3.75 million
honest wagner psa 2 slow for 3.75 can
you see it or no here let me give it to
you yes uh here you go right here right
here right here you gotta write oh okay
you're looking at the wrong one i don't
know i think what the wrong yeah i was
gonna say
mike trout in 2009 super fracture
autograph sold for 3.9 million patna
homes sold for 4.3 million luca
on his birthday is sold for 4.6 million
lebron james rpa rookie patch autograph
sold for 5.2 mickey mantle 52 tops
sold for 5.2 million that's a psa 9 by
the way that's not a ten that's a nine
that sold for five point two million and
then honest wagner
t206 sgc three sold for six point six
million dollars oh are these people
crazy for spending this kind of money on
cards no um not only are they crazy and
a lot a lot of people talk about cards
and they don't understand what trading
cards realistically
are a serious collectible you know
people who buy ultra high-end trading
cards are the same
type of people and the same mindset of
people who buy uh
van goghs renoirs were hauls um and
things of that nature
what you have to realize and i'm going
to give one example teacher of six
honest wagner now t206 means you know
tobacco and it's just a designation 206
was the serial number they gave back in
the 1930s and 40s when they were coming
up with a catalog system of cards but
the set was issued in 1909 and they put
the cards in packs of tobacco you know
either pipe tobacco
one brand was chewing tobacco but
basically cigarette tobacco and they
would stick the card in a pack
um those cards became very very popular
was it turn of the century had ty cobb
cy young christy mathewson everybody but
honest wagner the legend goes did not
even though he you know was a big big
cure of tobacco did not want to promote
tobacco the kids so he demanded his card
was removed from circulation interesting
and um it became very very scarce and
very desirable
if you go in history and you look at
every single time that card is sold is
probably in the vicinity of 50 known in
various conditions graded uh you know by
the various companies
but if you go in history and look at all
of the sales of a t206 wagner and what
i'm about to tell you
i don't think you can look at and
compare to any piece of art any any
precious metal or any stock
every single time an individual honest
wagner has sold and changed hands it was
for a higher price than that exact same
card sold previously so if you look at
all approximate 50 cards and you look at
all the hundreds of transactions every
one of them has had since 1909 there is
no documented case of anybody who bought
a hoeness wagner whether they bought it
in a horrible condition or they bought
the best one possible has ever bought
the card and resold it and lost money in
fact this chart is already outdated
because a
graded 3 psa 3 honus wagner sold about a
month and a half ago privately uh for
eight million dollars
so and i know
you know there are other cards on here
that if they sold would shatter if ken
kendrick ever sold his t206 wagner 8 he
would get 40 million dollars plus
the first person to sell a 52 tops
mickey mantle in a psa 10 there were
three of them is gonna get over 25
million dollars if any of them ever let
it go and i've tried aggressively with
with all the owners um we tried together
one time together yes i made an offer to
you yes yes yes you did yes you did it
was a pretty aggressive it was it was it
was a fair offer however these
individuals um you know there there's
only one that's a potential target what
number did i give you the day you and i
spoke
i'm comfortable if you say publicly what
number did i it began with a two i don't
know the exact yeah so there you go so i
made an offer to buy that i really
wanted this car but it is what it is at
this point yeah and um
basically
the
mass produced cards you know that you
buy in a store today out of a pack that
are not random that are you know that
are just you know
they produce tons of that's not what
we're calling talking about the
investable assets we're talking about
the investable assets are the truly
rare cards of the all-time great players
whether it's a hornets wagner whether
it's a michael jordan whether it is wilt
chamberlain whether it is um mickey
mantle willie mays you know wayne
gretzky for example as as you've learned
and and you know to give an example you
set a record for the highest price
hockey card ever sold and then the card
was resold after that for you know
half a million for three and a half
million dollars i sold it everyone's
calling me oh my gosh bad 2.1 million
for the two cards because i did the tops
on the opt six months later sales were
three and a half million dollars the one
card yeah the one card one
and by the way the guys that bought it
from me the tops people that bought it
from me were the rally guys that bought
it correct they sold shares of the rally
and the the
believe it or not on the opt-10 one of
the guys that was bidding ford is
wayne gretzky wayne gretzky yes
yep i got a call i was on a call with
bruce mcnall and i'm sure you know who
bruce mcnall is and they call me they
said hey let's see if we can do
something here with this card i'm like
look it's between you or it's between
heritage heritage was coming to me i
don't think you and i had done uh many
kind of dealings at the time yeah yeah
and uh so
they came through and then we're like
okay let's try this out but i think it's
gonna suffer this much okay and they
said we guarantee the guard's gonna sell
for a million dollars we think or else
we can take the what do you call it the
reserve off yeah i said okay sounds good
next thing you know it's 11 o'clock at
night and i'm sitting there getting text
messages here's what it's sold for but
so so in other words what you're saying
right now is
these folks that are buying all these
cards they're not making any they're
they're not dummies they're not now who
who was not in the market that's now in
it meaning like you know at first
bitcoin it was all you know oh my gosh
it's because fiat currency and i don't
know and then next thing you know all
right i'll buy a hundred thousand
dollars okay i'll put a million dollars
and the next thing you know
michael sailors of the world i'll buy
you know this many i'll buy this and
then elon musk and then hedge fund and
then mutual funds and then okay now it's
legit right
what have you seen yourself having been
in it from 78 today what were some of
the events that completely changed the
card business and who's entering in the
market today that maybe 10 20 years ago
would have never even looked at it well
the biggest thing that changed the card
business was really the creation of uh
psa the authentication and grading
company in the uh early 90s you know
prior to that you know and it's always
funny when people pull out these um
mail-in publications from like 1979 i'm
13 years old and it says you know ken
gold and garwood drive cherry hill new
jersey uh which was my address at the
time and you know i would say mickey
mantle vg-ex
very good through excellent so it was me
my
non-professional but but you know
somewhat trained eye calling the card
very good excellent the person buying it
they didn't see a picture of the card
they didn't know if the card was
authentic or not
they
had no independent grading authority
what psa did when they came into the
marketplace is they did two things
the first thing they look for is is this
a real card that is the most important
thing is is it is it not a reprint is it
not a counterfeit is it not a forgery
that is always going to be the most
important thing the second thing they
did was they established a grading scale
between 1 and 10
with 10 being gem mint and one being
poor and what that allowed people to do
as they gained trust and as they gained
market share and acceptance was people
were able to buy a card site unseen and
you were able to buy and sell the card
in a commodity so for example if
somebody ran a hedge fund they can say
okay fine i want to buy
five lebron james rookie refractors in a
psa 10. they never had to see the card
they never had to look at the card they
can put it in an asset portfolio they
can line list it as in 2003 tops chrome
lebron james refractor psa 10 and
it had a value so that between that and
establishing the price guide what that
allowed to happen is it went from when i
used to go to card shows and people
would just go to card shows as a kid um
to now being able to buy and sell over
the internet and buy and sell you know
at first early in the late 90s it was
ebay and then obviously companies such
as golden um you know where we you know
sell you know tens of millions of
dollars of this stuff virtually every
week but now the people that are enter
and not just collectors you have
individual investors you have serious
collectors you have the entire foreign
market in 2012
literally i would say less than a tenth
of one percent of golden's business was
probably overseas buyers
now i would say 25
of all the weekly new registers are from
outside the united states you know not
25 percent of our volume yet but 25 of
the new people coming in in addition you
have these fractionalized share
companies you mentioned rally so you've
got rally you've got um collectible you
can can you tell people what these are
how it works so what happens it's
basically it's crowdsourcing what they
do is just like a stock you know you
talk about tesla tesla has probably
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people that own a tiny tiny tiny
fractional piece of the company that's
what the sharer stock represents so what
they came up with said okay let's take a
collectible let's say the collectible's
worth a hundred thousand dollars and the
customers can't buy it uh you know
because an individual can't buy it's too
much but what if they want to own a
small piece
so let's say you can take a hundred
thousand dollar item and sell ten
thousand units of ten dollars each to
represent now somebody can own a tenth
of a percent a hundredth
and that is what happened with rally and
your uh wayne gretzky tops rookie card
that's even what happened with rally and
a copy of the declaration of
independence i sold rally a couple years
ago a t206 honest wagner that was a
psa excuse me it was i think an sgc
authentic it went out at an issue price
of 500 thousand dollars which people
thought was high at the time right now
it's trading on their platform at two
million dollars
so it is uh that's crazy yeah and by the
way rally uh correct me if i'm wrong
rally also helped collectors who owned
the cards increased the value of the
cards because now they're buying
now there's more people that are
participating so the card that i sold to
rally for whatever number they paid for
the tops i think they paid 800 grand for
it
immediately that card went up to 1.2 1.3
million because they were selling the
shares yeah so rally kind of helped
increase the price of cards i just sent
you the link with declaration of
dependence if you want to pull that up
but please continue oh so so that is a
big part of it also now there are mutual
funds that are
buying cards there are
dedicated trading card funds where you
know i know uh one company has is
already i think on their uh their third
different fund to buy trading cards that
are buying cards that started with a
company called uh blowout when they did
the blowout wax fund talk about a fund
you wanted to get into because they did
it really before the boom uh they
started it i think in
2019 uh before the you know before the
whole covert boom with collectibles um
but they took sealed wax product like
this and they just said okay fine we're
gonna put a uh two million dollars of
sealed wax into a fund and now the fund
has a value of about 11.3 million
dollars
um but you've got hedge funds out there
that are allocating a percent of
resources to it so it really has become
an alternate asset and you've got people
um like tiger investment group that uh
you know they go out and they say can
you can you speak at our conference and
can you do this and people want me to go
you know all over there and you know
somebody will be talking about art
somebody will be talking about um real
estate and i'll be talking about uh
trading cards is that what's going on
tonight is that kind of what's going on
that's that's that's exactly what's
going on tonight yeah okay so so adam
did you have a question i think you
wanted to ask something i'm learning
over here i mean i do have some
questions but we'll get to that so so
what what do you own that you'd never
sell
uh so one of them and we did we did i
guess we did a watchdown with uh with uh
with drake where he showed off his new
watch and i said i never wear i'm not a
big jewelry wearer i don't wear watches
however this was a special occasion so i
wore
my 1956 new york yankees world series
watch
that was uh george weiss's who was the
president of the yankees and in the hall
of fame
so i wore that watch and uh it was most
all the players and
the team they all selected rings you can
get do you want a ring or you want to
watch and the yankees had you know
players want rings but you know the
manager casey stengel and the president
said i've got so many rings already i'm
going to take a watch so i own his watch
from 1956. is that kind of what it looks
like uh the one the rolex to where it
says on the left there you go right
there something like that yep
so um except my my guy because he was
president he got his studded out with
diamonds so it's it's it's uh
sick that's a sick rolex yeah can you
imagine that i know so you own one of
those i own one of those and you never
sell that no no no and i own a um you
know because i'm i'm a big man i'm a
card guy but i'm a big memorabilia guy
too car look cards
to me are more of an investment and less
personal i don't necessarily have an
emotional attachment to a trading card
um you know i i have i do have a
complete t206 set i do not have a wagner
but i have a plank which is about a 250
000 dollar card as part of the set uh
you have a complete t20 i have a
complete two or six set yes really yes
uh someone's got to gift you honest
wagons yeah
they're just guys
if we you know if we go public um and i
sell some shares and you know then maybe
i'll use some of that money to complete
my set with the wagner
um
but uh the other thing is i own uh babe
ruth's bat from 1927
the year he hit 60 home runs
it's a psa 10 and it has uh provenance
directly to claire ruth
when she gifted it
to um the babe ruth museum back in the
uh early 1970s that that's that's gonna
be uh very very good yeah that's that's
that's in the millions yes
you said that
the one thing you would not sell is the
yankees rolex watch
right yes is there because you've been
buying and trading and selling is there
something
that you're like i would not sell this
card yeah you sold your your gretzky you
got a couple million bucks boom is there
anything you would not sell i don't have
i don't have the card that i wouldn't
sell that's the problem
if that makes any sense the card i want
that i would never sell i don't have yet
got it but i'm a patient guy so and and
this said card we won't name names if
you did somehow acquire it it's yours
for life i don't think i would sell it i
i don't think i think it'd be in some
kind of a museum that i would keep you
gonna tell us what it is he knows what
it is he knows what it is
there's a couple options and two of them
we've discussed already
some wheels are turning over here
i remember when i first started coming
to the dallas office php valuetainment
and i saw that there were
boxes of cards of your
top
guys your your employees your your
contractors yeah your sales guys so
was that some of them was sort of the
motivation i already got the idea of the
baseball cards for our sales guys from
ray dalio because he talks about in his
book
in uh principles he says they have cards
for all their other guys yeah it's a
very good idea about it we have it for
all our guys every year we give it away
are those worth anything to our guys it
is we're giving it away
if i got my hands somehow on a ricardo
aguilar card
i would hold on to that for the rest of
my life i would sleep with that on your
eyes
some of ray's um that's bridge order
right
some of his uh smartest best and
brightest are um extremely
high-end uh trading card collectors and
investors if that if that tells you
anything about the mindset of people
that makes sense to me though to be able
to do something like that okay
so uh uh the box do we want to open the
box or not do we want to kind of start
opening the box or we want to wait till
second half for
matt to be here and we'll wait how far
is matt away from here by the way
uh uh uh uh uh tell me by the way we
have um
uh what number do we have we have two
super champions the moment we get to 20
whatever the amount is the moment we get
to 20 super chatters we'll open a box we
got 18 more to go but i got a couple
questions here for people that ask one
guy said rejoining the hobby over a year
ago this is gokur i noticed a horrible
drop in the quality control and customer
service can do you believe panini has
intentionally has been intentionally
reckless due to losing contract on sole
manufacture
that's a question
um so here's the thing i i think that
the trading card companies over the past
couple years have been dramatically
overwhelmed
and um you know my viewpoint as a
collector is i would think that if i
open up a new pack of cards you know
nobody's ever touched it right every
card should be a 10. if it's not a 10 at
least it should be a 9. now a 10 is gem
min that means perfect a 9 means mint
which means they can have a tiny
imperfection like maybe off center left
to right top to bottom or on the back
but that's my viewpoint as a collector
every time i open up a pack of card if i
handle it properly every card should be
a nine or a 10. that is not happening
and that's what he's referring to what
has happened is the increase in demand
has forced them
to
go to other places to print cards that
may not be
um used to playing cards to handle the
overflow production the other issue is
is as companies like panini produce
these ultra high-end cards like flawless
like eminence which was
horrible to get graded uh it came out i
think they cancelled it because it was
so difficult to you know keep the
quality yeah but the cards are so thick
they're making such a big surface area
that they're giving so much area on the
corners to get touched up and to notice
that there's a tiny ding on it so yeah
look people have been opening up cards
of some of those products and literally
be getting a five or a six right out of
the pack because the card was mishandled
um the other issue and the problem that
you know companies like panini and tops
have is when you have an athlete
autograph a card
you know they're handling the card so
the athlete's gonna sign a card and he
might drop it on a table all of a sudden
it's got a ding corner you know and
that's you know it's a signed card of
that athlete but it's got a digging
corner so all these things play but yeah
a hundred percent um i would say if you
look at
trading card product produced in 2012
through 2016
the
the ratio of cards that are perfect out
of the pac were pack were higher than
they are now but no there is zero chance
that panini is mad that they lost their
licensing to fanatics and is
intentionally uh producing there's no
way poor quality cards no panini
wants to sell as much product as
possible while they have their license
they want to make as much money as
possible and
possibly they want to look good as
possible so they can be a takeover
target by fanatics just like tops was a
takeover target you know it look it only
makes sense for fanatics to want to
start making trading cards earlier than
2026 in basketball and football and the
top end that uh panini and fanatics work
at a deal for the licensing i hope so
because it was a brand that everybody
was swearing by and talking about for
for many many years silly white boys got
a question here says let's get that
that's his name by the way yeah
let's get that box open ken have you
gotten into tcg like pokemon and yugioh
if so what's your opinion on them sure
so first of all as a personal collector
i do not personally collect tcg however
my eight-year-old son paul is a big
pokemon collector
i also for those of you who follow me
know that i
have broken pokemon cards with logan
paul and
you know i'm friendly with him and logan
is actually an investor in golden
so
i recognize and he's a huge he's the
biggest pokemon guy out there he wore at
wrestlemania two nights ago put the
picture up he wore this cartoon
in fact that's why that that card is not
on here that's a list is also outdated
because he paid five point two seven
five million dollars for that pokemon
card right there you see a psa ten yep
and he paid five point two seven five
what makes that card so special it's um
so what it is it was a special
promotional card
of pikachu one of the most loved
characters like he's designing the
pokemon cards it's called called the
illustrator there are only i think there
are less than 40 that are known making
it in theory rarer than a t206 owner's
wagoner although it was made a hundred
years after um so it is a modern card
but it is it is basically the hoeness
wagner of all pokemon cards and this is
my viewpoint on pokemon on tcg
um and it's also my viewpoint on comic
books um which i think is really a a a
blossoming investment for you know for
collectibles
baseball is really a u.s sport um you
can say you know asian sport as well but
you know you go and go to go go to the
street and ask a kid do they know who
roberto clemente is do they know who
willie mays is a lot of them won't um
ask a kid if they know who joe montana
is they're not going to um ask a kid if
they know who charizard is pikachu is
batman superman spider-man wolverine
they're going to know and it's going
what a point so you have
you you have a worldwide population i
don't know how many people in the world
right now is it five billion eight
billion eight billion jesus escapes so
eight billion you have access to the
entire world where they know these
characters whether it's the tcg
characters like the pokemon or yu-gi-oh
you know or the especially the marvel
and the dc characters i mean marvel is
part of disney now so
years from now people are going to say
oh my god
wolverine actually had a comic book
spider-man had a comic book and i can
own the creation of that or i can own a
action comics number one the first ever
superman or a detective 27 first batman
or batman number one so i think that i
really like all of those areas long term
based on the fact that it has
you know a constant replenishing of the
potential people who uh might be
interested and buy that product very
cool the uh alan uh carpool just asked a
question my son who was 13
purchased a rare 2016 bowman chrome
tatis fernando tatis autographed a
rookie twitter number to only three
right before the coveted card boom what
do you think that card is worth now oh
my god okay so the um two let me put it
to tease but let me put this in
perspective for you
so that's a variation it is i believe a
retail variation not out of the hobby
box so if you compare that to a red
refractor of tatisse
which is limited to five
autographed that's going to be in the
range of
250 to 350 000 for the card
so this card
um i'm not
great with the retail versions but it
could potentially be uh fifty thousand
dollars plus on that card that he pulled
could be a 16. so 13 year old kid got a
50 000 auto card there you go good for
him gotta love it by the way this is a
25 000
box
that will open up here in the second
half shortly but so so another question
for you
in in when it comes down to i saw you
the other day you talked about a player
that i also feel is undervalued a card
an investment that's undervalued who do
you think is overvalued today who do you
think is undervalued today so one i'll
kick it off for you and you can go from
there you said willie mates i agree with
you i think willie may's fully
undervalued i also think the guy's
jersey i'm wearing right now i'm wearing
a ruth
jersey it's not a mantle it says ruth in
a bag
i think ruth is undervalued i don't
think ruth is uh
actually uh getting the value the card
it deserves i may be wrong i want to
hear your thoughts but what would you
say is overvalued what's undervalued
um
i don't want to get too much into
overvalued because people will like you
know people who hold that card will like
get get mad at me
i would say that i think that there is a
lot of speculation on
basketball players who have
less than three or four years of
experience in the league and whose
career could potentially end
before they accomplish anything in the
nba and on those type of players you
need to be careful i think on some of
the younger baseball players who have
not made the major leagues and people
are buying what they hope is future
value on those cards again you know you
look at steven strasburg of uh the
washington nationals could have been the
greatest picture of all time but
constant arm surgeries and injuries um
look at jacob degrom i mean he is the
best pitcher in baseball right now and
he might not play again this season
crazy because uh you know my man steve
cohen uh unfortunately he gets mac uh
gets scherzer and now uh you know de
degrom um is is out i mean he's trying
really hard to win a world series you
know i'm not talking about the mets yeah
yeah steve for those who don't so steve
cohen owns the mets um he is also one of
the um
you know on my board of directors and
one of my larger shareholders so um i
root for the phillies but for him i also
root for the mets so it's disappointing
to see degrom get injured but i think um
players who are a little bit less
established without the track record
that would be the area i put into
overvalued i also think
cards like
people
i i what's what call it's worth base
cards and you know
this is a pattern you always see that
this is going to happen 100 of the time
you open up a brand new product the
product first comes out people pull the
base cards of the hot new rookies they
get them graded those highly graded
cards
sell for a lot of money
they always go down
they're going to go down because there's
a small number of supply at the
beginning and people who rush out so
it's a very good point okay you know
like the people people buy them when the
pop population report is maybe 500 at
some point that population report may be
50 000. so
don't rush in you know i'm not talking
about a card like a one of five that's
you know the cards that are numbered
individually in the card that's in a
different stratosphere the cards that
are not numbered in the newer product um
don't rush out and overpay them at the
beginning of the product cycle because
they'll go down product i think is
undervalued um
i think
first of all i do think that willie mays
as a baseball player is drastically
undervalued um i think that most of babe
ruth's cards are undervalued i really
like the baltimore newsrooth i really
like a car his what is called his true
rookie card called his 1916 sporting
news card to me that is one of the five
most iconic cards of all time because it
is the first professional rookie card
of babe ruth
and the highest grade of that card
sells for a fraction of what the highest
grade of mickey mantle's card sells for
for example um i think
vint i think the older guys in
football and basketball compared to the
modern guys are dramatically undervalued
whether it's a chamberlain whether it's
a russell whether it's a uh you know a
giannionitis whether it's a jim brown
whether it's a joe namath those guys do
not get the uh do not get the attention
i think that you know i'd like to say
that uh
soccer is undervalued but you've seen
such a big boom in the past couple years
that it's really caught up like i have
you want to see something crazy
so this is something we're going to hand
out tonight look at the numbers on messi
and ronaldo
and during the during the time period i
mean that 2016 this card very important
2016 this card sold for 8 600 that's a
messy card
four years later it sold for 116 000
this year it sold for three hundred four
thousand dollars that's a nineteen
thousand eight eighty four
increase rate of return holland sold for
33 then 148 ronaldo sold for
dollars in 2014
4 000 and 20 is this is this accuracy
thousand dollars in 2017 and 320 just
the exact same card so
those numbers were based on the exact
card the exact sale of that card insane
24 000 percent return 24 000 in a span
of four and a half years yes that's
insane so you're saying soccer is one as
well to look into zion williamson is it
is it a is it a too risky at this point
is it buying i sell hold well
to hold okay you can't i don't think you
can buy it okay um but if you have it i
think you have to wait until he comes
back and uh performs um there's a lot of
hype built into zion i would say
it's uh definitely a hold i personally
would um you know unless it's like dirt
cheap i think zion is such an amazing
player he's such a potential dominating
you know dominating athlete but is he
you know how often is he going to play
how often is he actually going to be on
the court is the problem
yeah they they showed uh the
image the other day i think the nba did
or esp or sportscenter did say in the
first three seasons zion's only played
three more games than odin did yeah in
his first three seasons and you know
what happened to greg odin portland
trailblazers you know and he's done yeah
and the other as a category i think that
overall
uh
sealed vintage wax product and i'm
talking about vintage you know in this
case i'm saying anything that's like not
in current production because
every all these cards you know as they
get graded the what's called the
population report how many exist go up
but every time a box is opened of one of
these classic products
that's one less in existence for example
86 flair i'm an idiot yeah i'm crazy i
opened up a 300 000 box of cards with
drake
there's one less of those boxes in
existence right now okay so um yes we
pulled all the jordan rookies but it's
kind of like they say keep it sealed in
the original box so and i think that
that is a real safe bet because you go
out let's say you buy a 1996 box of
basketball cards keep it sealed you've
got kobe bryant rookies in there you've
got allen iverson rookies in there
you've got steve nash you've got ray
allen you've got marlberry you've got
all these guys it's a bit to me it's
like
a basket like the s p where if you see
it and i think it's a safer bet than
speculating on one individual player
like i like
2011 baseball because you've got mike
trout and bryce harper
in inside the box so it's it's just a
really cool thing and that that's one of
the things i've i've collected over the
past few years i totally agree with you
but keep it in the box except for this
one right okay that's fine
we're over 20. so if we want to open it
up if you want to take the lead with
that we're over uh i got a i got a quick
question so
we're talking about these older cards
right 86 fliers the older honest wagners
people that are watching today that
decide they want to go buy some cards
right can is it still relevant today and
where can you buy cards that would
eventually be worth value like walmart
or a trading card store or a hobby store
let me let me first of all i'm talking
about the vintage product um but uh
realistically the majority of the market
is modern and you know i can we've sold
probably 20 different lebron james cards
for a million dollars or more um tom
brady there exists hundreds of tom brady
cards that are a million dollar plus
people with the modern product because
the way they produce it back in the day
they only made one version so the 86
fleer there's no michael jordan card
that there's only 10 of or or five of
every single box of 86 flair has the
exact same michael jordan card in it but
today
you know you can open up a um you can
open up a box of cards and say okay
lamellar ball
there's going to be different variations
of him there's going to be some that you
don't know how many are printed but many
others that may say one of one which
means it's the only one of that
particular working existence one of five
one of 50 one of 99. so there are people
that are getting really rich by either
being incredibly smart or being
incredibly lucky there's going to be
somebody who opens up a box of flawless
and has a four million dollar lebron
james card once that triple logo man is
pulled that's what drake is looking for
there's people that open up something
called bowman chrome um and bowman draft
which is where tops puts all its rookies
and young players there are people who
are going to open up and find what's
called a super fracture it's a one of
card it is like um you know the ultimate
card to own of that player and that's
going to be super valuable almost no
matter who it is but if you have the
next young hot prospect like we sold
jason dominguez uh for half a million
dollars he has never played a game in
the majors he's probably two years away
he probably will not see the major
leagues at the earliest until 2023 we
sold his rookie card because it was a
one-of-one for 500 000 because they're
projecting the future value and saying
hey when derek jeter was a rookie he did
not have a one-on-one card so what's a
risky building
of course it is it's it's it's it's high
stakes how you know high risk high
reward you know though the modern cards
have a higher beta associated with them
than the vintage cards the vintage cards
you know
if you want to if you want to put money
into vintage cards and then just have
them slowly appreciate that's fine the
modern cards you can buy you can spend a
hundred dollars and literally have a
card the two years later is five
thousand dollars just so people want to
know what the psa grading service how
backed up are they today
check this out by the way i don't know
how backed up are they okay so a year
ago psa was 12 million cards behind
i believe that they have reduced that
backlog down to about four million cards
and um you know what that means is this
prop they're probably you know they used
to have this service called bulk
and people would be able to send in 100
500 5000 cards at a really discounted
price and what that did was it log jam
the entire system for everybody so you
could have a 25 000 card and your card
was stuck because somebody with a fifty
dollar card sending in for eight dollar
grading service and you know they're
they're there in front of the line so
what psa has done is they've opened up a
way where people if you've got a card
basically that's 500 or more you can cut
the line you can pay they've got you
know a fifty dollar service and a
hundred dollar service all the way up to
ten thousand dollars you send a million
dollar card you're gonna pay ten
thousand dollars to get it graded but
you know to get a graded reel and you
like the grade it's easily worth the ten
thousand dollars but yeah if they if
they all they did was concentrate on the
other surface
they are probably um
six months i'm gonna guess to uh to get
rid of uh that backlog all right i gotta
ask i gotta ask
seems like this is like the hottest
thing on the planet right now
clearly yep so here's why you're not
gonna get offended by this i hope not
but
i remember a time when i was a kid and i
was collecting you know 86 mets and i
was like it was like a big deal i was a
kid and then i grew up and i was more
interested in
hanging out partying chicks the whole
thing
now this is kind of cool again i mean
let's just use what you're saying you're
hanging out with drake yep you're doing
things with logan paul i saw you on your
instagram you're throwing touchdowns
with tom brady
steve aoki's opening up a card shop with
our boy dan fleischman like it seems
like the cool kids are in this market i
remember a time my buddy josh he might
be listening
maybe five ten years ago he told me he
was collecting cards i'm like you're a
straight up nerd bro straight up yup
nerd alert
why why is this a cool thing now it's
basically seems like you and the card
game has gone from geek to chic please
explain is it all about the money that's
my question is it just simply it's an
asset class there's money there you know
follow the money the cool kids are in it
now drake's in it what's going on well
it's it's definitely part because if
it's an asset class but it also
it gives you honestly
there are first of all there are people
who just love the cards they love the
look they love the design they get
excited opening up packs but do you you
bet on sports
not anymore okay i've been to ga it's a
problem okay okay so but let's say so
you've you've got people about sports
right yes they like sports don't they
correct okay i'm a big sports fitness
okay don't get it okay fine so if you if
you bet a game of sports do you feel
that you have any control any control
over whether or not you're going to win
that bet
no
well if unless i know uh tim donaghy
yeah if you if you said you did you're
you're lying or you're or you're a
delusional okay because if you bet
sports you know
it the theory is it's 50 50 but less
than 50 because the house takes money
the difference between sports and cards
are is trading cards especially modern
cards could be a little bit like sports
betting however
you actually have some control of your
outcome
you can go out and decide okay fine i am
a baseball expert and baseball's the
best one because a lot of people don't
know the young players i can go out i
read the scouting reports i know i know
information about this guy i can put
money into him if you're you know a
basketball player let's say let's say
you went to university of kentucky okay
and let's say you saw tyreese maxie and
you know tyrese maxi went way lower than
he should have in the draft when the
sixers got him in the 20s and you put
money on tyrese maxie when he was you
know some of his cards were 50 dollars
or 28 hours or 500
those cards have about 10 to 30xed
since he was drafted so you when you do
when you do something in trading cards
also it lets you root so all of a sudden
guess what it doesn't matter if you're a
knicks fan you want a bunch of tyrese
maxi cards you're a 76er fan and you
want tyrese maxi to do well so it is is
like sports betting however it lets you
have more direction it lets you have
more control and it lets you use your
expertise a lot a lot more than betting
a single game
okay very good way of explaining and
having and having a fluke a fluke tip
tip ball run back for a touchdown
something like that so so that is part
of the reason part of the reason is an
alternative asset class the other part
of the reason is that breaking cards has
become entertainment you know i was
breaking a box of cards with drake and i
had hundreds of thousands of people
watching i broke a box of pokemon cards
with logan paul over 10 million people
have seen that video on on youtube so
all of those things have transformed and
when you look at a company like fanatics
i mean here you take a company that had
no sales
no history of sales no employees and
when they initially went out to take
investments i think they got a four
billion dollar valuation
so
that shows you the
what the market thinks and they're gonna
they've so much money invested and there
they've tentacles everywhere
so they're going to have the players
promoting the cards the leagues now own
a piece of the company so you're going
to have you know the leagues promoting
it and you're going to have commercials
you're going to have all these things
which is why i like everything that's
out of print
because the theory is
if you 5x the market or 10x the market
guess what they have to do they have to
print more product right they've got to
make more product in 2023 24 25 26. so
i'm going back 2019 and earlier and
that's the type of stuff i'm buying
because if they are going to bring all
these new people into the marketplace
they're going to want to buy something
you know that was pre-night pre-2024
right there you go did that answer your
question
you feel a little bit more comfortable
about it essentially the answer is it's
all about the money and it's if you want
to diversify
uh rather than
picking a sports betting a random game
you get a player can i ask a follow-up
show of course so it says here that you
know because i'm a big just invest in
the s p index fund i don't do individual
stocks you know who knows what's
happening with the market yeah who knows
what's happening with tesla but i'm very
confident the s p is going to go ten
percent year over year every year as it
said so let me just read you some
numbers here if you invest ten thousand
dollars
uh in the s p index in 2007 you'd be
sitting on 71 grand right now so
7x your money if you invested that 10k
into an index cards for trading it'd be
worth 165 grand not so bad so over
double that so
um to your point picking out cards
individual
individuals is there an actual
index
for cards like if i said look i don't
know if
i want a tray young or a zion or a brady
i don't want the responsibility of
picking this one card whether it goes up
or down who knows is there an index that
people can invest in just like the s p
500 no there there are funds out there
there are a couple card funds out there
i know that a company called alt has a
has a fund i know that blowout has the
wax fund which uh
i like as well and i know that there are
other entities that i think they're
doing it more for for private clients
there are indexes like if you go
get an app called card ladder um it is a
pricing tool and they have like an app
of you can check sports by basically
typing baseball basketball and they have
a bat they have a basket of the most
highly collected uh cards and they show
you what the trend is on that individual
card but no
as as it gets bigger it would be great
if there were
readily
accessible funds the closest thing to it
now that you can buy without being an
accredited investor is probably the
fractional share companies
you know whereby you can buy an
individual like hey you want to go out
and get mickey mantle cards you know buy
shares of mickey mantle cards or buy
shares of michael jordan or lebron james
that's the closest thing to it what are
those companies called again uh you've
got rally you've got otis you've got
collectible there's a new one coming out
with some ultra high-end uh items called
uh liquid marketplace i think they're
launching in the next month or two um
but those are four groups
that would be um you know if you're
looking to do that type of thing cool
very helpful we're ready
go forward lead the way okay so let me
just get these reading the way lead the
way okay so adam what are you learning
so far tyler are you a card guy at all
or no
uh after this episode possibly i used to
when
if you're watching this right now i'm
curious what has this done to you
because you know the one thing about
investment a lot of people are like why
do you why do you interview uh you know
there was an era i was interviewing a
lot of bodybuilders i get so many
complaints why are you interviewing
bodybuilders i don't care about
bodybuilders your business channel why
are you going to be mafia people i don't
care about mafia it's a business channel
why do you interview card people these
are the things i'm interested in yeah
i'm interested in collectible cards but
if the audience is listening and you put
a little bit of time into it there could
be a pretty good return for you with
carts how are you processing today's
conversation well at the end of the day
just to circle back to what you said
whether it's bodybuilding whether it's
mafiosos whether it's even the ken golds
of the world everyone's an entrepreneur
and they're doubling down on their
specific skill set so i'm learning that
ken is an expert in this
and you know how they say that the
riches are in the niches ken's
getting rich doing this and he's
following the most beautiful thing in
life is they're making you are you are
you sitting there saying no ten percent
of my money goes into cards if there was
an index fund yes because
part like you used to keep
200 cards on your desk
if the maid got you know feeling uh some
type of way she stole five of the cards
you won't even notice boom you're down
50 grand so for me
i wouldn't want
like a card tied up in my here you go my
house so that there's been a solve for
that like for example if you go to uh
golden auctions yeah or if you go to uh
you know where now we shorten the name
just to golden golden dot co not com but
golden dot co
and you click on vault uh what you can
do is
you can vault your cards you can have
them digitized so that um
you know you can see the carts and you
you know there's a price guide
analytical tool as well for it so people
buy like literally right now we've got
about 125 million dollars worth of
product of individuals product in this
secure vault it's fully insured you
never have to worry about you can log
into your account you have a portfolio
of all your cards if you sell a card you
can give us instructions to ship the
card to somebody if you want to put it
you can you know click and you can list
it on uh on on golden to uh you know be
sold or for auction so and there are
several other vaults out there i'm
obviously i'm i'm golden so i'm going to
promote mine um but and it's a actually
a completely free service there's zero
cost
we insure it for free the other thing it
does is
if you buy something let's say from an
auction house elsewhere
and you are in a state that collects
sales tax the vault is located in
delaware therefore you ship it to the
vault and um there's no you know
you deduct sales tax off your invoice
the old delaware approach yep so there
you go so you're saying that you don't
necessarily have to hold the tangible
card correct but pat you have all your
cards correct me if i'm wrong almost all
of it not all okay so why do you hold on
to all your cards rather than using the
service it's going more in this
direction but you know
if you
some people have places where you put it
in the safe because guests are coming
over you open up the car you kind of
look at them there's something about
looking at your cards if you're an old
that's how i am i like to take my cards
out once a month and take a look at what
percentage
like i feel like
there's three different classes of
people i mean if you're struggling and
you're poor
you know and you're not making a lot of
money just save up save your money like
save that money like have cash yes like
don't just try to get a mickey mantle
rookie card and then you're broke okay
cool then there's the person who goes
from just all right i'm trying to be a
saver
to try to become an investor now the
first thing maybe you should do is have
a 401k ira like get just the basics and
then the third class a person is maybe
someone like a pat is like dude
i'm good i got the cash i got the
investments now let me look to diversify
my asset class so rather than just
stocks businesses real estate now you're
getting into crypto nfts cards you know
certain sort of uh rare collectibles
coins what have you gold even is that
essentially the basis for investing or
what do you recommend like who should
definitely not spend all their money on
cards and who should step up to the
plate and actually diversify people who
uh need the cash in the bank to cover
food rent and insurance should not be um
not be spending it on carts okay that's
you know that's i i
you know i think that
level number two i know a lot of kids
that are in college
that literally have
a you know come from middle class
families have seven figure bank accounts
and seven figure card collections from
from buying and selling and investing
over the years um i know some some 21
year old who goes to school in
philadelphia i've been trying to hire
for two years i can't because i
literally can't you know can't pay the
kid 150 000 a year because he's you know
you know making 5x that uh with cards on
on the market like as we have golden up
here uh you know that's an obviously
another place you can buy we're more
high-end like we have an auction running
right now we have items that may range
from a thousand dollars to over a
million but virtually every name we we
spoke about except the honest wagner
whether it be mickey mantle whether it
be lebron james michael jordan jackie
robinson babe ruth all of those items
are you know available in some variation
at golden right now
but
getting back to uh the box you know look
i there are people i deal with i think
they're little nuts there are people
that have 90 percent of their
um investable assets in cards and they
feel that they want to invest in what
they know they feel the stock market is
manipulated they feel that people are
crooked they don't believe you know they
feel there's not free trade and they
feel with trading cards you know they
have a competitive advantage and that
they can hold the assets and they can
control what they buy and what they sell
um and not be up there where you know
some i don't want to pick on any
publicly owned company but um you know
where they own i will pick on one uh
because i was stuck with some of this
stock um you know where they got peloton
they thought they got a great deal
buying it at uh at 80 bucks because it
was down and then they you know goes
down to 30 because they you know
announced when they put out their
earnings that oh by the way we've been
really sucking for the past couple
months and we didn't we didn't give
anybody advance warning um so
but you know they don't want that to
happen to them you know they don't want
that to happen to them and they don't or
they or they look at the financial
crisis um you know
you could pick one but in 2020 when they
said some people you know the covet came
out and you know everybody forced the
market down and all the billionaires
bought it all up cheap and now it's
higher than it ever was right so they
want to have some control and you know
typically the younger you are the less
likely you are to uh to buy stocks
thank you let's open it up sure let's
let's lead the way so this is this is
this is what's called the uh the hot
pack so we're gonna do this last okay
okay um now the key with this card is
tell me what why you why is it called a
hot pack because this has this is a
hobby exclusive
and it has a guaranteed called a an x
factor in here which is one of those
rare cards guaranteed guaranteed
there's one guaranteed x factor in this
box
so what we're looking at and um
with these cards they are um let me move
this over here there you go yeah i
should have brought a um should i
brought a mat
notice how he carefully opens the pack
yes in fact
his hands are
not dirty okay here we go i'm gonna want
to see who i got okay so we have
and these you gotta be careful not to
touch you get cory mcgetty we able to
see this by the way if you can yeah if
you can put the camera uh
can you guys zoom in one of the cameras
john if you want to come in here or
george so we can zoom it in okay
corey mcgetty okay duke i remember him
steve francis kyle tv franchise yeah
kurt thomas
miami heat
checklist we don't want that
what is that card do you say it's a
checklist this is not okay
and mike's sweetness okay
no georgetown
what i will tell you is people can say
oh my god you got fingerprints um
some people open up cards with gloves
you can damage the i find you can damage
the card that way because you don't have
the real feel and what people do is they
can take a microfiber and just clean a
fingerprint off it and anytime you any
time you send a card out to get grading
if you're not taking a a
a microfiber and touching the card to
make sure you're removing your
fingerprints you're downgrading your
grade now again there's only five cards
per pack there's only five cards per
pack excuse me four cards 24 packs per
box four cards per pack i gotta tell you
the cards are cooler than i remember
they're like they're they're like almost
risen a little bit we got here matt
harper
jalen rose
rose 81.
you know what's 81. pavlovic
what's 81. kobe scored 81. discord
yeah travis hanson okay travis hansen i
don't remember that guy at all
here we go
this box so some of these cards are just
whatever some dude who never made it
whatsoever and then you got guys like
steve francis who's arguably a hall of
famer yes you got a lot of rookies and
also these guys all made it they're all
in the nba mm-hmm um okay
so we got oh is this able to show it all
if you can't zoom in
yeah we got jorge on the case if poor
his mom we're going to be okay brent
barry who was one of the greatest
fantasy players of all time because he
had amazing
very wow you won the dunk contest yeah
bobby jackson great point guard
minnesota banks
marcus banks come on unlv we need a
lebron out of this box yeah we do ken
okay well we just pulled a good rookie
because i sold the back okay okay so we
have a um we have a better rookie
um it'll be the last card let's hope
there's more in this pack
model definitely definitely a future
hall of famer in the back of this pack
you know
no no no no no who do we got there no
that is ginobili he's definitely he's i
think he's genuinely he just got us into
the hall of fame eddie curry
bost
richard hamilton reparation
hall of famer
he lives right across the street from us
oh you know it's serious ken just busted
out that plastic covering and what do
you got there ken
a chrome
carmelo anthony wow
you've got the carmel anthony
you can put that right in the plastic
yep absolutely
shout out to you buddy this way you guys
won't get your fingerprints on it what's
something like this go for
um
it's it's it's not a thousand dollar
card but at least at least at least it's
300 few hundred dollars so a rookie
mellow
nuggets
we got rookie in the back of this one
not the rookie i want to see
okay we got latrell sprewell
well
joke is coach out here the first thing i
thought about quran butler
quran
assistant coach of the year murphy and i
gotta look at these carefully just to
make sure i'm not skipping over a uh
refractor
i probably have already because the
refractors they're the same front but
they're just shiny
so and all these cards are kind of shiny
so again is this basically what you did
with drake this is exactly what i did
with drake yes now the difference with
the 86 flear box is because they were
all well-known players mostly
you um
you had a lot of cards that everybody
wants to get
andre miller
and they also only had 132 cards in the
set this is a much larger set andre
miller very underrated point guard jason
yeah he was actually pretty good terry
the jet
jarvis hayes
okay
come on
pat's just looking for a dennis rodman
rookie card that's that well that would
be 1988. see he knows
88 same year as pippen i believe right
that flier yep exactly one set wally
zerbiak wally wally's kwame brown talk
about directions
great podcaster
tyler this one's for you ty we got to
get kwame on the scene
he's he's blown up by the way he has
blown up like if you two years ago his
card would have been irrelevant now who
was he fighting with was it um
he was getting into it with uh a
commentator like matt barnes and uh
all the smoke pods steven a smith was
that the one who was oh it was stephen
stevenson yes it was steven smith you're
right okay
you're right well who doesn't have beef
with steven a smith okay so we have nice
you can see right here we have a
refractor you can see the difference yep
yep okay so let's hope it's somebody
who's good because if it is that'll pay
for the box eric snow
nope eric's kenny hardaway yeah second
best player
to penny penny no no
no he just said a penny oh
we have a good card what do we got what
do we got oh we have a really good card
we have a tracy mcgrady game worn
sick t-mac okay so let's get that
tracy mcgrady game worn jersey yes you
have uh
25
refractor okay so we pulled
the first one is i've actually pulled
the 2003 chrome can you um can you uh
zoom it in it's uh
see if you're on it or not
so i got tilted tracy mcgrady
that's the angle right there if you got
it that's the camera okay you see it or
no
okay good yeah they can see the back let
me show the back you can see where it's
got the congratulations and you got the
number 25. it's 1 out of 25 yes
so what's something like that go for
i couldn't even quote this off about my
head so it's i've never um
i know
okay
so that's good let me
put this in here too
tmac
could have been going down as one of the
best players ever if he avoided those
five out of 25. that's so good so that's
a good one and then we got the last one
is uh josh moore
okay never even heard of him all right
we got team mac here
oh wow it's a little piece of his jersey
in the card it's actually pretty dope
yep
game worn shorts
so they cut off a little piece of his
shorts and they put in the cards put it
in like what they started doing yeah ken
i remember back in the day when i was
growing up in the 1920s
it came with gum please god be good here
you go pbd all right let's see what we
got here
oh crap
okay we got a really really really good
card but not of a really good player
gary payton
okay gary pete what do you mean no no no
no no no no no no we got seven would be
1990 or no 92 i believe right uh peyton
i think would probably i think peyton is
that i think 90 91 yeah uh eric coleman
same year as coleman i believe it's
arunus ogaskus so this is what's known
as a black
refractor it is one of the holy grail
cards
if this were lebron we'd have a half a
million dollar card right now who's that
whose card does that this is mike miller
three-point specialist for the heat yeah
memphis grid now if you can even
something like that is that in the few
thousands or no um i only if it's a 10
yes
so this is um limited to 500
but the black refractors are very very
tough
because it's because of the border to
get you know really high grade so this
one is definitely
this one's perfect
that's what i was so mike miller mike
miller was uh he won it for the yeah
game seven okay now uh ken if you could
somehow pull an rv to sabonis the best
passing big man of all time
i would love that who was a four who
would that go to was that you and i were
so when you open these cards with drake
and every first card had the stick of
gum on it how much how many cards are
actually high value cards that you can't
get the gum off of um luckily with drake
we had dude there was none on a jordan
and none on any of the key rookie cards
um they don't do the gum anymore right
no they don't do gum anymore luckily but
they used to why did they put the gum in
there it was because the top started as
a gum company it was bazooka you know
bazooka joe
that would be a good card if it was a
refractor
then may just like elvis one name only
that's right and maurice williams
nuggets okay you remember in the name oh
william
yeah i'll do one
yeah let's do it all right tyler do you
want to do one
i'm interested
all right let's see what we got here
pvd
okay
so the way you're doing it is
so i go like this
i take it up top
i hold the edges and i just pull it out
so that it can go like that and then
once i get it once i get a seam
i just carefully peel them
hmm
take it at the top
can you grab a scissor
so you're just pulling it off do you
want me to um want me to start the packs
for you guys i would love for you to do
that i could see myself pulling this
apart and butchering it pbd would you
send that to ken
if that's that if that has my arvida
sabonis card in there
i'm running out the studio ken
nick van axel oh yeah plays so much with
the lakers before kobe it was nick van
axel yes yep
i got a dejuan wagner
do you remember the one right yeah of
course came out of high school i believe
keith van gaal his son is the number one
uh number one high school player in the
country really point guard yep wow
outlaw
he played for um adam let's see your
luck adam here we
i go this guy
duncan's rookies what year huh what's
what year is duncan 99. duncan is uh is
92.99 is 1997.
uh david robinson yes in 99 that's
something i got drunk hold on hold on
i don't know what just happened here
what but i got a kobe okay
i got a kobe bat there we go this is for
you pbd so let's get this let's get it
what do we do with there i just pulled a
call me brian
is that a draco worth anything or no
no that's so cool put it in here put the
kobe in here too you're going in you see
this i just got a kobe
pat because i love you so much i'm
giving you my kobe card unbelievable
please go serbian here thank you
i got jamal mashburn who i just saw at
the heat game the other day good for you
man yeah
what what story you know about jamal
mashburn
i don't know he was doing some shady
stuff in kentucky what do you got
jamal mashem remember the three j's
jason kidd jamal mashburn jimmy jackson
jimmy jackson yeah that's right amy
jackson i got brian grant
and a very underrated big man zaza
pachulia
remember zaza did brian grant play with
is that his brother or no no right
because now you're thinking of harvey
grant horoscope no brian grant was a
heat guy with dreads
i think he's run into some health issues
recently
um but he got traded with lamar odom
to the lakers i got a ricky davis
car malone car malone matt harping
harp ring and then i got a rookie
nah i don't think that is
john stephenson
here you go
ken i appreciate you um
opening up the cards no problem
by the way the only this is below
graphic the only time i open up plastic
stuff i guess if i'm opening up a condom
so this is uh
that's my old days sorry guys use
protection that's all i'm saying okay
reggie miller
oh i got a refractor
not a great guy but here's refractor and
i'll show you guys how you can tell the
uh
difference
sean marion i mean you got a matrix
by the way i i will say this i'm feeling
very childlike right now this is like a
cool feeling
like i haven't done this stuff and let
me see how you can tell so you can 30
years the um
refractor you have to notice that this
chrome is a the chrome's a little dull
here and it's a little bright here and
you look at the back and you see the
bottom left if you see 160 it's a
refractor
if you see what color like these or it's
not the color it's got to say number 160
no no no no no it's got to be shiny so
you really have to be able to see it so
i probably should look at your guys
cards when you're done to see if you
passed over any uh see if you passed
over any refresh i think this one might
be a refractor is mike dunleavy jr shout
out to the uh you see someone done
leavey family this one seems a little uh
and what's the big deal with refractor
somebody's trying to collect the set and
they need to have total refractors right
getting refractor sets are like is
highly expensive and virtually
impossible checklist
now what are these checklists for uh so
you see you know who's in the set oh wow
okay no this is not a refractor okay
so these are all 0.304 these are all
three not rookies though just they
played in the league yes they were in
the league in o304
some of these guys antonio
damn david west oh
come on where are you lebron
i'm gonna put that here
there you go short lewis
lowest great thing i just pulled a dirk
refractor
yes i did okay nowitzki
so if there's ken if there's one
player in the league
not like a hall of famer not like an mj
lebron but like a young up-and-comer
who's maybe been in the league for the
last two three years and you can get
your hands on his rookie card who would
it be
you're talking like a luca is it a trae
young john miranda look look obviously
obviously john morant is doing amazing
his cards have gone up luca is uh doing
amazing um his cards have are already up
there i mean luca has a lot of
expectations built into his into his
card prices but he you know he certainly
he certainly can dominate the dominate
the league i think trey has come off a
little bit this year
um you know i i like um i think tatum is
you know
he is really
might be undervalued the guy
i'm going to mention somebody is going
to be a home buddy um but i think is
really undervalued and that is uh joel
embiid oh my god um giannis
certainly look what if giannis wins uh
four championships and five mvps so he's
got one championship he's got two mvps
it looked like embiid was going to win
the mvp this year now it's probably a
toss-up between embiid and and uh
yannick
you know well yeah yokish as well jokic
is uh he's an interesting guy yeah he's
um he does not have the type of game
that inspires collectors
yes
he's the reigning mvp he is the reigning
mvt but there are there are some players
who are amazing players but or
underpriced like for example james
harden people don't love buying james
harden um
cards i think james harden is you know
drastically undervalued for what he
accomplishes he's got to win a
championship to get that respect yeah
exactly i don't know do you think
giannis can win a championship according
to tom zenner he'll never win one i
think
yeah by the way
i think giannis is that anything it's
nothing over there no nothing over there
okay so we got what three more packs
left we got yeah we got
three more and then we've got we got
three more and then we've got the the
money pack thanks john let's see what we
got here
let's see what we got here ken thanks
for making me feel like a child again i
appreciate it buddy okay i got a pretty
good rookie in the back let's hope it's
a refractor
it's not now again how old is your son
my son is eight so
is there anything more in life that you
love just opening up cards with your son
oh it's great it's great it's great you
do this with dylan or tico
pbd yeah i would do it just they they
they like uh uh pokemon cards see that's
like what ken was saying another
refractor but paul is really into
baseball and uh
that's your son baseball and basketball
yeah yeah so i am i'm remarried so i
have a 25 year old daughter and a 22
year old daughter who until so tell me
what this is you may want to look at
this okay let's see oh no look at this
what this is
oh there you go we got it what do we got
i pulled the lebron [ __ ] we got the
lebron fire
congratulations
this is it this is what we wanted
nicely done pvd so and right behind it
look what's right behind it though ken
that's what you got to see what's behind
it
whoa
oh
wow oh he reaches for the glasses you
know it's legit oh
he's got the carmilla rookie refractor
this is sick dude this this was the hot
spot so pat pulled out the hot pack yes
pat
congratulations
so there's that
this is a carmelo refractor rookie yes
yeah
i don't know i just pulled the boris d
out guys i don't know
okay the french connection pretty decent
defender though this is really good very
versatile i'm very happy we got these
two cards
way to go so this is it fair to say that
that lebron card just paid for the pack
yeah yeah yeah way to go pbd yes
there's a
carmilla
let's see what we got we got
desmond mason oh i got something good
coming up scotty pippen
i got a chris bosh rookie
chris bosh is also uh correspondent
that was it by the way oh three three
they call it one of the best if not the
best right yep correct
oh three right there and you wade
here we go
darko milicic oh oh i just pulled maybe
the best looking guy in nba history
you guys know who sam casella is of
course absolute stud
doesn't look like an alien at all
you are too funny
tim thomas oh
damn okay so we have
it is
jason richardson x factor j rich
what a dunker how many how many dunk
contests did he went to
so this is what's called an x factor you
look at it you can see
i'll pass it down limited to 220
but they put it in the uh holders back
in the day so that you would um
not get the car damaged
when he when he came out i mean people
thought he was going to be a bigger star
than uh
this guy had this guy had
an interesting game yeah
you could jump through the roof you just
couldn't want to see if any of these are
practical before we set them aside yep
okay
take a peek
twenty five thousand dollar box huh
interesting
so now to get these cards graded it's
going to take us how long
um
i can get them graded pretty quickly
okay i i know somebody can know somebody
so i do just give them to you to get
them graded we can take care of that for
you right
perfect we have phone calls if you want
do we let's get them but it's got to be
about cards it's got to be about cards
okay
well let's do them let's get some of
these callers in we've got drake on the
line drake how you feeling buddy hey man
we have kyle
kyle let's give kyle kyle what's going
on what you got
hey good morning guys
um i'm just watching the pack getting
open and watching you guys talk and uh
just had a question on what you guys
thought the fanatics deal
would have on the industry going forward
um
i have an answer either either one of
you weren't answering no you have the
awareness and you're the expert okay
so
the let me give you the negative the the
downside is that you know you never
really love monopoly right you never
want one company controlling all the
licenses
setting that aside
i think that this is potentially an
unbelievable historic moment here's
what's happening right now in cards you
know these flawless cases i was talking
about that went you know going for forty
thousand dollars plus i fanatics got
under ten thousand dollars for those
cases
so what happened is that the middlemen
are the one that ones that are making
all the money
uh fanatics is what their goal is to try
and put more cards directly into the
hands of consumer so
they will get more money for the product
but the same time they're going to
eliminate a lot of the you know the
distribution people who you know if i
own a card store why wouldn't i just
want to call fanatics and buy myself why
do i want to go through a broker so what
that's going to allow them to do
is charge more for the product which in
this case is not a bad thing because
they're not charging more for the
product they're actually getting it to
the customer less so let's say panini
instead of getting eight thousand
dollars a case
got twenty thousand dollars for those
cases that are selling for forty okay
and the consumer was able to buy them at
twenty thousand dollars a case directly
from panini so the consumer would be
buying them at a cheaper price
uh panini would be getting more money if
you get more money per product you can
make a better product you can put more
money into the product you can buy more
autographs you can buy more jersey cards
you can spend more money on advertising
fanatics is a 27
per the last evaluation 27 billion
dollar company that's insane so so they
are and they have and this is this is
what i love
they have a 20
year license agreement with everybody so
i've competed against michael rubin in a
former life when i was selling on uh tv
back in my group he's the owner of the
76ers michael rubin one of the owners of
the 76ers but the owner of fanatics the
principal is that how he made his money
that's how he made his money so fanatics
so he's the principal shareholder of
fanatics um
and uh you know he's a very smart guy
he's very strategic so they have a
20-year license so you know what they
don't have to do they don't have to
flood the market in year one two and
three if you want to make money in the
card industry this may be my best tip
for everybody today
whatever whenever fnatic starts putting
out new product okay under their
licenses
buy the first two editions the first two
key editions of baseball
basketball and football you know you you
got to wait until their product filters
and the reason is is if they are smart
you know they got 20 years they got they
got to pay these fees for 20 years they
got to make sure that their first few
releases
blow up in value
to support giving them a track record so
i think what they're going to do is is
they're going to really create great
product the first i hope they do it for
20 years but certainly the first few
years they're going to create break
great product they're going to under
produce to make sure they get people
excited that the customers make money on
the cards the customers enjoy the cards
it's a great experience for everybody
and set them on a great track record um
i am excited for the industry uh with
the fanatics deal because i think it's
going to drastically expand i think it's
going to give consumers a chance to get
product at a better cheaper price and
enjoy the appreciation as opposed to
somebody that you know somebody who has
you know just taking possession of the
product for a week and selling it uh
making the money um plus i think it's
going to get a lot more players involved
they've got player relationships they've
got all these athletes signed the
contract um getting really in the weeds
it used to be back in the day like this
jersey card that you that we pulled to
tracy mcgrady guess what it was worn in
a game by tracy mcgrady uh the past
couple years the jerseys have been so
hard to come by they're like literally
they're like shelf jerseys like right
off they go to dick's sporting goods and
do it so fanatics is gonna make sure
they're actually game used and buy the
game use stuff and put it on the card so
i think that they are going to make a
better product for consumers and i think
that the initial purchase price by
consumers are going to be at a more
affordable and more realistic price
ken
what is the
maybe it's a black swan event i don't
know but is there something out there
that's that maybe would be a worst case
scenario for the cards like yeah get
involved in the cards different asset
class but oh we didn't see this coming
and all of a sudden the market goes down
20 50 what would that be in this
marketplace well for me the um for out
of production product i don't see that
event okay because the products already
out there you know like obviously with
any athlete um you you can have an event
like there were you know
desean watson recently signed okay um
obviously he had all the charges um you
know last year two years ago and his
cards went all the way down so you know
with any current living athlete should
they do anything to put themselves in
disfavor with the public that can hurt
you're seeing more individuals than the
actual market more individuals in the
market the only thing that can hurt the
market is the card manufacturers putting
out a dot of a product or over producing
those those are the two
those are the two major risk factors
what do you think i should do with all
my oj simpson rookie cards those have
gone down quite a bit i i don't think
they're going to come back i think i
think yeah i mean i think the novelty
you know the novelty of uh you know tim
being a murderer has uh graduated
yeah well they did win the civil case uh
so
but um
they uh it is a um it has
weakened over time you know i was around
during that during when it was actually
happening people are going crazy for
stuff and for his autographs during the
chase but you know the interest is
slowly waned over time right okay let's
get to the next caller john if we got
another one let's go to the next one
yeah we have chris on the line chris how
you doing what's on your mind doing
fantastic gentlemen nice to see you guys
kicking off on monday open up back cards
with the boys um down to business so i i
have just a question for ken um
currently have an entire base set first
edition pokemon cards um
majority of the shinies are graded 8.5
and above okay now looking at the market
it's very difficult to read because i'm
kind of a unique position where not a
lot of people have an entire set so my
question to you would be how would you
approach that would you go through an
auction would you go through
what would your approach to be to go
ahead and sell those if i was interested
to do that well sure the the every time
somebody tries to sell on their own what
you've got to realize like i'll use
goldman's example i can touch a button
and i can send out an email that 500 000
people can uh can get at any one point
in time so if you look at if you look at
pokemon for example you know we did the
break with logan paul and we sold those
packs on
golden so we have all the high-end
pokemon collectors that are at gold and
if you try to sell yourself let's say
you try to sell it yourself on ebay
you don't know
who's going to be watching you don't
know what type of following you have you
don't know if the bidders are actually
bidding because there's no controls over
who places a bid and you don't know if
you're actually going to get paid with
the larger more established auction
houses and marketplaces they approve
their bidders they watch the bidding
they make sure you collect they're going
to highlight it they're going to
advertise it you're not going to be one
of 75 million products listed so you
really want to try and find
the uh the right place to sell it and
really the right auction for example
going in
you know if we have like next month at
golden we have a um you know jackie
robinson auction okay that probably is
not the ideal place to sell pokemon
however after that we have a non-sports
comic book video game and tcg auction um
that is certainly more likely to attract
people who are interested in pokemon
than something that's generic
wonderful i thanks so much for the time
guys appreciate it great feedback by the
way great feedback thank you chris next
person john
we don't have anyone else zach hung up
but he did want to know about ufc
trading cards and are you interested
yeah ufc has really been taken off um
um we're lucky that conor mcgregor
follows us and he's retweeted some of
our tweets every time we've sold a
record of his card but ufc again it's
it's worldwide it's relatively new the
trading cards um there are they are
rapidly gaining an audience not only for
the fights but rapidly gaining an
audience for the trading card collectors
and it is a it's a hotly contested
license so yeah i like ufc cards going
forward you got to get your hands on one
of these paddy the baddie cards that's
my guy yep that kid's going to blow up
patty to batty you know that guy yeah of
course i know because great
i i bought a uh i bought connor's best
card
uh which was the autograph and i think
it's like one out of 25. if you know
which one i'm talking about connor has a
uh 30 000 it wasn't a lot of money 25 or
30 000
and with things like aaron rodgers would
you say aaron rodgers is underpriced
right now undervalued right now ooh
that's a good one um
i would say i would rather buy i'd
rather invest in
aaron rodgers cards
than
say
patrick mahomes cards really and i'll
tell you why i'll tell you why
i think that you know first of all he's
a packer you know second of all he's got
so many mvp awards he's going to go down
as one of the all-time legends and i
think
that his cards lost a bit of a shine
uh last year during the whole
you know unvaccinated i'm not vaccinated
thing and i think his cards went down
the further we get from that people are
going to care less yep and he won the
mvp again and he won the mvp again okay
and he signed
the largest contract in nfl mahomes on
the other hand um i think that his cards
went up rapidly when people looked at
the rookie class and look at looked at
the nfl and say wow this guy's in the
chiefs he's just gonna rush through the
nfl for the next five ten years and rack
up five six super bowls what they didn't
see coming was justin herbert
josh allen joe burrow they did not
realize oh my look
there's an argument to be made that josh
allen is the best pure quarterback in
the nfl i mean you need the beast yeah
the gala bills yeah the guy is
absolutely you know amazing so i think
it's tougher i love patrick mahomes
cards i love him as a player but i think
it's going to be tougher for him to rack
up all those super bowls that people
expect people expect totally agree with
rodgers or rogers is
rogers really you know they talk about
basketball they talk about jordan lebron
and kobe rodgers would be part of those
those three whether it's uh joe montana
tom brady aaron rodgers i would say
though those would be my threat can we
talk about tom brady real quick sure i
mean he's gonna go because the goat
nobody's better than tom i don't care
what you say absolutely what happened
where he retired some guy bought his
last football as his last touchdown pass
for a half a million bucks boom the next
day hey i'm coming back like how much
money did that guy lose talk about
downside about buying no memorabilia in
theory had the guy bought it and paid
for it he would have lost probably 90 of
the value uh in actuality the the
football has not been paid for
um if that was done if that transaction
happened at golden i just simply would
have reversed the transaction because i
don't want you know the the ball was
advertised as his last ever touchdown
and literally the day after it it voided
um there should have been a disclaimer
in there right they could have put
something in there that said hey tom
brady is retired as of today it's his
last football i provide you never plays
another nfl game then then then they'd
be covered right now they're probably
if uh the auction house leland wants to
press it there probably will be a
lawsuit it'll be interesting to see uh
who wins but obviously it's gonna cost
him a lot of money but no that ball was
worth for a second 500 000 dollars plus
and then it becomes worth what a tom
brady
touchdown during the playoffs is worth
which is uh really nice but certainly
between 25 and 50 well assuming he
actually does come back and throws
another touchdown correct yes right
tyler how are we looking all right real
quick uh we opened a twenty five
thousand dollar box right can you
ballpark i mean you had seven or eight
good cards right maybe ten yeah can you
throw a ballpark number on what uh what
it was worth
um
a lot of it depends on what that
mcgrady's worth i don't know off the top
of my head i know the carmella is a few
thousand lebron interestingly the lebron
during the height of covid was probably
a 28 000 card now it's probably closer
to uh 10 000. so i'm going to say in the
teens um how high in the teens you know
we'd have to go card for card and see
what the grades come out cool well ken i
really think all
it's really cool that you agreed before
the show to split this three ways that's
really nice
you're a gentleman
i appreciate it thank you guys tomorrow
we have who we have uh uh so we have
kevin
tomorrow tomorrow dave rubin thursday
joe jorgensen friday and you know it is
bitcoin week in miami there's some big
speakers at bitcoin special guests
aaron rodgers is speaking as well i
believe there's a there's a few big
names that we're talking about
it's a big week that kicked off
with the card king himself okay thank
you everybody we'll see you guys
tomorrow night am thank you ken for
coming i appreciate you this is
wonderful great experience thank you
everybody bye
you